[Müzik]
değişim birkaç bin yıl önceye kadar
çamurdan tuğla bile yapamazken bugün
kendimden zihninden feyz alarak bir
benzeri mekanizmayı oluşturacak kadar
gelişen insanların değişimi
uygarlık daima devinim içinde olan merak
ve gelişim arzusunun bir mahsulüdür
gelişmişlik için üst sınırı tayin
edilemez Çünkü insan ortaya koyduğu Her
yeni buluş yapıp yöntemin yepyeni
getirileri karşısında merakına Dün
olduğu gibi bugün de yarın da yeni
düşecektir
dolayısıyla her Teknolojik ilerleme
insan toplumuna yeni koşullar sağlar
bu yeni koşullara dikkatle
değerlendirmek ve değişen ortamın yeni
normali tesis etmek üzere etlik ve
toplumsal uzlaşı bağlantıları özenle
Kurul
malı en başta da dile getirdiğim gibi
insanlar olarak artık zihinsel
işleyişimizi formülize etmekle
kalmıyoruz dahası onunla çalışan ve suni
çözümler üretebilen mekanizmalar ortaya
koyuyoruz üreticiyi üretmek beraberinde
çokça soruyla getiriyor
bilinen veya daha doğru tabir etmek
gerekirse bilindiği sanılan mevcut
bilinç yağını bugün yapay zeka olarak
adlandırılan bir öge ile iç iç
E peki ortaya çıkan
bu durum bireyin ve toplumun hareket
yönü nasıl olmalı
burada önümüze çıkan başlıca sorulara
beraber cevaplar üretip
Neyi nasıl tanım
adığını toplumun kendini oluşturan
bireylerin haklarının güvencesi ile
alakalıdır O halde çıkış noktası bireyin
tanımı olan bir
birey bana göre genel durum akışına
irade ile müdahale edebilen iradesini
insani ve doğuştan var olan duygu ve
muhakemeler
inden alan Özgün genel durum akışından
olumlu ve olumsuz etki Göreme gelir
burada temel dayanağımın varoluşunun en
ağır tedici özelliği olan duygu ve buna
bağlı Özgün yargıya varma olduğun
un Yapay Zeka kavramı ise kapsamı
dahilinde Ayrıca değerlendir
in yapay zekanın hayatı kolay kılan ve
insanı eliyle kontrol altına olumsuz bir
komplikasyon halinde kolayca müdahale
edilip zararım önüne geçilmesi mümkün
olan bir işleyişe sahip kısmı Elbette
geleceğin Muazzam güzellikteki
getirilerinden biri
Fakat burada benim eleştireceğim ve
endişelerimi dile getireceğim Yapay Zeka
kendisinden koşula bağlı olarak amaç
sebep sonuç üçgeninde hareket edip
eylemde bulunması Talep edilen ve
kontrolü sağlanamadığı adeta Mekanik bir
insafa terk edilmiş olan bölümü
insanın bir de yanlış güdülerle hareket
etmesi ve toplumu yahut bir başka
biriyle ilgilendiren meselelerde de hani
değişkenlerin sınırları haddinden fazla
aşarak Gafil bulunması ihtimali göz
önüne alınıp bunca önlem ve Tabiri
caizse sigorta sistemi tesis edilmişken
aynı yahut benzeri programlamaları tabi
tutulmuş Hatta yetkilendirilmiş bir
Yapay Zeka vasıtasının sebep olacağı
budurulması güç dersinden maalesef
arbederler çıkarmaya
Bu sebepten dolayı birey sıfatını ve
bunun altındaki benim şahsen meşru
gördüğüm yetkileri yalnızca insana
mahsus kılacak bir düzen keza bu düzenin
dahilindeki tabirler her zaman nisbi
olarak daha isabetli ve sağlıklı
sonuçlar Doğacaktır
birey ve toplumun hareket yönünün nasıl
olması sorusunun cevabı Az önce
özetlediğim sebeplere dayanarak yapay
zekayı kontrol altında tutarak merkeze
insanın bireyin faydasını gözetmeyi alan
ve yapay zekaya ona Mecburiyetten ziyade
ondan istifade esasıyla yaklaşan bir
görüş olmalıdır
Bunun haricinde yapay zekaya birey
olmanın avantajları
yahut kendisini karar yetkisi verilmesi
gibi durumlar verilmesi halinde Belki
daha fazla ayrıcalığın tanınması halinde
müzakere edilebilecek hakiki bir özne
olmaksızın bu grilliliğin eyleme döktüğü
düzensizliği ve terörü maalesef geç
görmesek geri dönülemez boyutlarda
yıkımlara yol açmayı çok
seviyoruz Peki bana endişe veren kısmı
atlattığınıza göre faydalı gördüğün
yapay zeka ve benzeri teknolojiler
hayatına nasıl entegre edil
Ancak bunun öncesinde birey sıfat ve
yetkisine muktedir gördüğümüz insana ve
insandan Mahmut olan toplumun olması
gereken noktayı belirle
insan öznesi konuşmanın başında
kendisine tanımadığın özellikleri Tam
manasıyla taşıyıp kullanabilmek için ait
olduğu ve tabii hakkı olan konumu terk
etmemeli
dir bu konuma Balta vuracak haller insan
iradesinin çeşitli sebeplerden gülme
durumunun ortaya çıkmasıyla
kısıtlanmasından meydana
gelir kalabalık toplumlar ortak ve makul
kuralların ihlaline sebep olan toplumlar
Ya Rab cezayı ilanı yetersiz kaldığı
toplumlar gibi gruplar ve hemen
kendilerini kısıtlayıcı üst yapılara
mahkum olurlar
insanın benliğini ve bu saydığımız
iradeye bağlı Özgür Özgün ve etkili
hareketlerini kısıtlayıcı bu gibi üst
Yapı yahut farklı biçimde gelişen yan
etmenlerden arınmış bir ortamda insan
öznesi ancak konumuz olan değişimin ve
beraberindeki gelişimin olumlu ve
bereketli meyvelerini yemeyi
başarabilecek bir
güce sahip Ancak ve ancak kendine alan
oluşturabilen hak talep edebilecek
durumda olan bağımsız ve Etkin olmaya
işler olmaya Ehil özneler varılan
değerlendirmelerdeki insana vasıtası
Avan
İşte bu özelliklere sahip bireylerden
oluşan toplumlarda yapay zekanın olumlu
etkilerinden ve ortaya koyduğu verimli
ürünlerden söz edil
ebilir yapay zekanın işlevsel kullanımı
insan mantığından Doğan durumların önce
oluşun akabinde üretim aşamasına
gelindiğinde gerektirdiği Efor
fazlalığını hafifletmekle mümkün
dür Şimdi artık güzel bir kısım bir
kenara bırakalım ve görüntüyü biraz
netleştirelim
Mesela bir örnek oluşturalım çok acil
barındıracak yer lazım
hiçbir Mesken mevcut değildir İnsan
tuğladan çamurdan bir alan
yapmak isterim insan Farklı bir
ikincilerdeki çamurları izler Onları
alır Ondan sonra onları kurutur Daha
sonrasında onları yere atar ve en
dayanıklı çamuru alıp işlemeye başlar
nasıl da rahat rahat anlatıyorum bir
daha anlatayım Ama bu sefer daha
gerçekçi
olsun insanlar başladı yürümeye 10 tane
bataklık gezdi en sonunda çamura battı
yoruldu yaralandı arada bulamıyorum
burada kırdı en iyisini
e başladı işte günler
güneşin alnında sıcakta soğukta karda
yağmurda eliyle taşla sopayla
ilk anlattığın teorik halini hatır
layın beline kadar çamura batmış
üzerinde taşlaşmış terleyip bir tat
düşmüş halini anlatmıyorum yine
Çünkü o zorlu ve Efor gerektiren kısmı
düşünmektense
dizmek o çamurla yapacağı tuğlayın
sonrasında 30 dolarla yükselteceği
duvarları biraz daha gelişip temel
ihtiyaçları atlattıktan sonra Farklı
durumlar için yapacağına düşünüyorum
geniş kapsamda kolaylık ve gelişmişlik
arayan herkes böyle düşün
ür Hayallerim planlarım yokluktan Sonra
gelmiş mevcut halimi düze çıkarmış
emeklerimden fikirlerimden doğmuş
yepyeni taptaze imkan
larımız niçin o rezilliği çekmektense
sonraki adımı düşünmeye zevkini tat
min ihtiyacı karşılayım sonraki keyfi
güzeldi
koşu düşünmek
yenilik ve teknoloji bireyi o bataklıkta
çamur içinde
teknolojik bir araç günlerce sürecek bir
inşaatta onlarca insanın duvar dikerken
helak olmasını engelleyebilir
yapay zekayla süslenmiş bir teknoloji bu
saydığımız kolaylıkları yaşayış
sanatının güzelliklerine göre Dizayn
ettiğimiz haliyle ortaya
koyup o benzersiz o Özgün ve insan
Zincirsiz
liğine güzelliklerin büyücü
dokunuşlarının sizi yaparsınız ve yapay
zekayla hızlı
ca ortaya koyduğunuz ürün ne aklınızdaki
tasarım hiç olmadığı kadar uyum ve eş
durum içindeydi
yapay zeka ile ortaya konan üretim
tatmin edicidir insana ve insanın
kullanımına Müsaittir
Tıpkı üzerinize mükemmel şekilde Uyan
özel dikilmiş bir elbise
gibi Yapay Zeka adam verim alarak
istifade insan evlilik sitesinin Muazzam
yansım
ası görüp teknik araçların her İhtiyaca
cevap verebilecek düzeye gelmesi de bir
başka avantaj ve yaşama vakit ayırmak
için eşsiz bir
fırsat tarla tapan ve yorgunluktan
dermansız kalıp yara bere olmuş ellerle
çıkan üç kuruşluk mahsulü bin bir
zahmetle o yorgunluğun üstüne kaynatıp
pişirip yedikten sonra kalkıp ertesi gün
aynı hareketleri tekrarlamaya mahkum
olacağınıza makul nüfuslu bir toplum
olarak gelişmiş yerlerde yaşayalım
ekinimizi yenilenen makineler yahut
networi vasıtasıyla kolaylıkla elimize
alalım
ihtiyacımızı hızlıca giderelim ki yazı
hayatınızda Bugün ne yaptın ne düşündüm
diye kendimize sorduğumuzda aç kal
Anladım açıkta kalmadım Başka da hiçbir
şey yapmadım diyerek saf saf suçluluk
doğal unsurlarla kavga edip boğuşur gibi
ondan nimetlere kan ter içinde
sökeceğimize gelin ağaç gölgelerinde
enfes bir havada nefes alalım ve o çok
iyi olmanı incelemesinde makineler
çeksin icabında iki vidasını
sıkıverirsiniz
buraya kadar olan dönüşüm program rahata
dönüşümü insan elinin mekanik kollara
dönüşümü Esasen bakıldığında
teknolojinin insanı kendine esir eden
rolde olmadığını anlatabilir
olması gerektiği gibi yani
hepsinin özetlemek gerekirse
teknolojinin yeniliğin dönüşümün amacı
yaparken sürecinden zevk almadığımız pek
kıymetli hayatımızın dakikalarını ziyan
Etmelere kıyamadığınız Leb demeli ve
yorucu gereksizliğin ortadan
misal araba kullanmaktan çok zevk
alıyorsunuzdur yapay zekanın sürücüsüz
araba teknolojisi size Fazla suni ve
zevksiz geliyoruz
Buyurun geçin direksiyonu Temple tefek
kullanın gezmediğiniz yer kalmaz gecenin
ışıklarında arkadaşlarımızla camları
açıp şarkılar dinleyerek sürün Ay Işığı
masmavi gecede denize vururken yan
koltukta sevgilinizle söylüyorum çekin
arabayı sağlayamaz mesela ellerinizde
böyle acayip gelişmiş mutfak aletlerini
kullanmadan Hazırladığınız şeyleri yiyin
ne yapıyorsak yapalım uyurucu bir şey de
olabilir yaparken harcadığımız zamana
değmesi için ondan zevk alalım
ama bir ürün bir hizmet hemen o anda
gerektiğinde ve zamanınızı başka bir
zevk için tahsis etmişseniz orada da
gelişmiş
de çekinmeden kullanırsınız
Yapay Zeka öyle geniş bir yelpaze ki
işte O baştaki de hşette zarlardan bu
yumuşacık zatenlere kadar farklı farklı
durumların imar ol
abilmek insan olmanın
hissetmenin yapmanın ve yapmamın kıy
metini bilir adamsın bizleri full
donatmontal duygusal kalabalık olarak
nit
eliyim Hakikaten de öyle Az önceki
tarladaki halimizi düşünün ya da duvar
dikerken ki
hissetmezsek düşünmezsek paslanarak yok
olacak makinelerden hiçbir farkımız
kalmıyor
çarkların içinde kalp bulamayacağınız
gibi damarlarınızdan da motor yağı
düşünülecek çok şey dua edecek çok yer
tadılacak çok lezzet ve gülünecek çok
şaka var öpecek bir sevgimiz var
değişip dönüşüp gelişiyorsak bunları
yaşamaya ve zevk almaya vaktimiz olsun
diye
dönüşüyor sözlerime yolda ciliyordun
şarkısında geçen şu sözlerle son
vermek yok
mutluluk kulağımdaki çiçektir sabahları
bir kuşun şarkısıdır harikaları benim
kalbim yaratır
bana hiçbir şey söylemediğinde bile
mutluluk Benimkiler üstünde
dudaklarımdır teşekkürler